tell us about this and and where that
drawing came from and so what happened
we I had never heard of anything called
a label and I don't know how many when I
went into jeans office and said Jean
what is a leg lamp and he said a lamp
with a leg on it and I said oh yeah of
course I had no idea and meanwhile these
guys bobbin and gene had had access to a
1976 piece of PBS footage where there
had actually been a leg lamp devised for
for some film and I didn't know this at
the time they probably knew that I
didn't know it either and they weren't
going to tell me which is just as well
so I went back to the art department and
sat down and did some sketches and
remembered a lampshade
in my my mother's house that I thought
was just perfect for this idea I
sketched something and handed it to
Martin Valluvar and to Mary and the
result is history I I don't know who did
the they did the vacuforming of some
woman's leg I don't know could have been
someone from the special effects
Department or somebody they just came in
well I I think you had the fishnets we
had a bet yes you didn't yes I thought
maybe married in yes I think the fringe
and the fishnets are the touches that
really make it work yeah and that
swooping shave very nice choice yeah
yeah because you could have a million
leg lamps but this is
yeah